on commence par du golf l'Open de France
à livrer son verdict ce dimanche après 4
jours de compétition sur le Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est le
japonais Rio issatsun qui remporte la
victoire le golfeur asiatique de 21 ans
gagne la compétition avec un score total
de -14 il devance de deux coups le
Danois Jeff Winter et l'anglais Jordan
Smith le premier Français Julien brun
terminant 6e position de ce 105e Open de
France on écoute le japonais
je ne pensais pas pouvoir gagner
mais j'ai gagné maintenant
je suis très content
c'est ma première victoire je suis si
heureux un peu plus tôt ce dimanche la
44e course Paris Versailles était
organisée à partir de 10 heures sur
l'avenue de Paris ria de GERFI accroche
un premier Paris Versailles à son
palmarès avec un chrono de 50 minutes et
45 secondes il devance le bolivien
Hector garibet chez les femmes samantha
fektos est imposé en 59 minutes et 5
secondes avec 3 minutes d'avance sur
l'américaine Catherine Golding le
rendez-vous a réuni plus de 25000
coureurs cette année sont partis de la
Tour Eiffel pour arriver à Versailles en
passant par la côte des gardes Kevin et
Guillaume Torin de coureur originaire
des Yvelines ont filmé ces images de
leurs courses on regarde
[Musique]
en football FC Versailles chute à
domicile dans le championnat de National
les Versailles se sont inclinés ce
vendredi sur leur pelouse face à
Villefranche Beaujolais sur le score de
1 but à zéro à l'occasion de la septième
journée après ce résultat les jours de
la cité royale pointe à la 15e place du
championnat à 3 points du dernier Épinal
prochain match ce vendredi 29 septembre
sur la pelouse de Nancy toujours en
football et dirigeants du PSG ne
seraient pas tout à fait satisfait de
leur nouveau son d'entraînement à Poissy
la raison il y aurait trop de vent sur
le Training Center certains salariés qui
travaillent confient qu'il est difficile
d'avancer lorsqu'il arrive de face à
certains endroits du lieu le bruit de
l'autoroute A13 serait aussi un élément
perturbateur pour le staff les joueurs
et les employés le nouveau centre
d'entraînement devait être inauguré à
l'automne mais la date a été retardée
enfin on termine par du rugby on jouait
ce week-end la deuxième journée de
Fédérale 2 plaisir s'impose sur le
terrain de Versailles sur le score le 38
à 21 de son côté Maisons-Laffitte
s'incline sur la pelouse d'Auxerre 25 à
19 au classement plaisir et premier avec
10 points vers ailles et 9e et le MLSGP
dixième